so they did an experiment where they
told a group of women that they're going
to put scarring on their faces or visual
disfigurements of some kind and then
they would go in into an interview and
the purpose of the experiment is to work
out whether the interviewer is going to
treat them differently because of their
fysal facial disfigurement what they
didn't tell the women is as they were
leaving to go for the interview they
touched up their makeup and without
showing them the facial disfigurement
removed the scarring so they went into
the interview thinking they're facially
scarred but they weren't and they came
back reporting massive levels of
discrimination specific comments that
the interview had made about them that
they perceived so you you you see what
you expect to see this is why teaching
people victimhood is so dangerous
because it makes them victims